et une autre stat et c'est vraiment
alarmante une femme est tuée tous les
deux jours et demi au canada c'est ce
que révèle une étude publiée aujourd'hui
par l'observatoire canadien du fémicide
alors sébastien les chercheurs veulent
donner un portrait plus juste de la
violence faite aux femmes
oui c'est ça la mission de
l'observatoire lancé en 2010 est à la
demande de l'onu qui veut mieux
documenter le félicite dans le monde
alors c'est le premier rapport de cet
observatoire une femme tous les deux
jours et demi vraiment ça de quoi
frapper l'imaginaire voici d'ailleurs le
portrait des victimes recensées par
l'observatoire en 2018
on compte 148 femmes assassinées durant
l'année au pays est bon au delà de la
fréquence les chercheurs font un certain
nombre de constats assez alarmant par
exemple il s'intéresse à la relation
entre les femmes et le présumé tueur et
ce qu'ils découvrent c'est que dans 53 %
des cas elles sont tuées par leurs
partenaires donc le conjoint ou le petit
ami et ça c'est un constat très
différent chez les hommes assassinés
chez les hommes assassinés ben on
constate qu'ils sont tués dans moins de
5 % des cas par leurs partenaires alors
cette année car qui témoigne de la
grande vulnérabilité des femmes qui sont
en relation avec un homme violent ouais
et parmi les victimes les autochtones
les femmes en région en milieu rural
donc sont surreprésentés oui à parmi
toutes les victimes d'assassinats donc
au canada 36 % sont autochtone alors
qu'elles ne représentent que 5 % de la
population et si oui on segmente
démographiquement on se rend compte que
les femmes qui vivent en milieu rural
donc dans des communautés de moins de
10000 habitants bien elle compte pour 34
% des victimes de meurtre au canada
alors qu'ils ne représentent que 16% de
la population et dans ce cas-ci l'étude
avance que c'est parce qu'il ya moins de
ressources dans ces secteurs moins de
centres de lutte aux violences sexuelles
et moins de refuge pour temps parce que
quand même plus de prévention exactement
jusqu'où blessé sur une bonne nouvelle
c'est que le taux d'homicides chez les
femmes au canada ces quarante dernières
années la diminuer une baisse de 52 pour
cent quand même parce que davantage de
ressources mais parce qu'on fait plus de
prévention aussi un peu d'espoir mais
moi si sébastien au revoir